eu vou te ensinar a engolir um lápis com
o nariz transformar água em coca-cola
fazer desaparecer uma caneta à frente de
toda a gente e claro eu vou fazer a
revelação de todos os truques de magia
ao longo do vídeo Então já acompanho o
vídeo até o final deixa o teu like Bora
lápis que atravessa o nariz
[Música]
que vocês apenas precisam de um lápis
super comum Ok então eu troquei é muito
simples vão encostar o lápis aqui no
nariz Ok vamos tampar o lápis
e enfiar o lápis obviamente que eu não
enviei o lápis pessoal Isto é só uma
ilusão porque o lápis veio para dentro
da minha palma da mão e movimento é este
sem a mão aqui agora vão apenas subir a
mão
convém que o lápis esteja destes assim
redondos Ok e convém também que não
tenha letras aqui escritas porque
reparem se eu fizer com as letras à
frente mesmo que eu faça isto as letras
continuam lá então vais estragar a
ilusão Então se foram lápis bem simples
é o que eu recomendo que desaparece
[Música]
para realizarmos a estrutura de magia
vamos ter que construir este pequeno
utensílio mas é muito fácil e do que é
que nós precisamos três coisas um
alfinete destes um elástico e uma caneta
BIC normal ok uma caneta destas vão
ligar aqui o elástico ao alfinete numa
ponta e na outra ponta vocês vão inserir
aqui dentro da tampa e dão um pequeno nó
aqui na ponta quando temos aqui o
elástico a ponta fica bem presa ali
dentro Ok Pois é só colocarmos a caneta
e fica mais ou menos isto e onde é que
vai ficar o nosso tecido mágico aqui na
etiqueta do casaco vamos colocá-lo aqui
sem estragar a roupa a atenção pessoal é
mais ou menos isto vocês podem fazer
este truque com qualquer casaco mas eu
recomendo mesmo que seja um colete assim
deste tipo sempre que eu fiz este truque
com casaca as pessoas achavam que eu
colocava a caneta dentro da manga então
se for sem mangas aí vocês vão ter
reações incríveis convém também que o
vosso casaco tenha um destes Box aqui
dentro porque assim dá a sensação de
tiraram lá a caneta OK agora que já está
montado o nosso utensílio vamos retirar
a caneta do bolso com cuidado para
esconder sempre o elástico com esta mão
Okay oh aqui está o elástico vocês vão
esconderem o elástico com a mão podem
abrir a caneta para a pessoa ver que é
uma caneta normal Ok mas sempre
escondendo o elástico no ângulo certo
Okay tampa ou a caneta e depois aqui é
com o treino vocês vão juntar assim as
mãos e num momento em que juntam as mãos
já vão largar a caneta É sim para dentro
do colete Aí sim puxa uma mão à frente
simulam que ainda tem a caneta e como
por magia ela desapareceu e eu já fiz
este Truca muita gente e eu garanto-vos
ninguém passa a mão nas costas ninguém
suspeita que ela poderá estar aqui e
nada de andar a revelar os truques aos
vossos amigos pessoal Este vídeo é
meramente educativo é para ti que estás
a ver isto em casa ok portanto não antes
pela escola a revelar o truque moeda que
fura a mão
[Música]
Como é que esta moeda é capaz de furar a
nossa mão a única coisa que vocês
precisam é de uma moeda pode ser
qualquer moeda mas eu recomendo sempre a
mais pesada Eu por acaso estou a fazer
com um centavos de dólar só porque tinha
muita aqui e achei bonita mas para o
pessoal de Portugal eu recomendo a moeda
de 50 centímetros ou de dois euros e
para o pessoal do Brasil eu não faço
ideia de qual é mais pesada mas já agora
comentem aí pessoal Qual é a vossa Moeda
mais pesada façam com essa vocês vão
colocar a moeda na palma da vossa mão
aqui bem no centro vão girar a mão e
quando giram a mão já meio que fazem
aqui um arcozinho para ela ficar assim
mais folgada sabem só para ela saltar
aqui dentro Qual é o segredo aqui vocês
vão passar a por cima e fazem isto dando
a entender que ela vai atravessar a mão
mas ela não atravessa fazem outra vez e
ela não atravessa mas enquanto fazem
este movimento vocês têm de colocar a
moeda bem na ponta aqui dos vossos dedos
aqui quase sair da mão uma duas Como
podem ver já está aqui bem na ponta a
terceira tentativa é a parte mais
complicada o que vai acontecer é que a
moeda vai saltar aqui da vossa mão e com
esta mão enquanto ela está esfregar
vocês já reposicionam a moeda bem cá em
cima esta exige estranho Então vai ser
mais ou menos assim um dois reparem que
a moeda já está aqui bem na ponta três
ela saltou e hoje eu estou com esta mão
aqui bem no centro e vai dar a sensação
que a moeda outra pessoa vossa mão
[Música]
Vamos à revelação
de uma caneta BIC bem comum ou outra
qualquer até pode ser uma destas um
marcador ou algo do tipo e vão precisar
também de um pedaço de elástico temos de
colocar o elástico aqui bem na ponta da
caneta
e colocar a tampa de forma aprender
muito bem o elástico aqui na ponta Ok eu
acho que tem que ficar bem preso na
tampa agora vamos colocar o elástico no
meio dos nossos dedos mais ou menos
assim OK Isto é Com estes dois dedos e
colocam elástica aqui bem no meio depois
esticam a caneta toda e o que vai
acontecer aqui o elástico que vai gerar
aqui alguma força e vocês têm só que
soltar a caneta aos poucos há várias
formas de fazer este troco Ok podem
simplesmente instalar os dedos e soltar
tudo podem mexer assim os dedos Como se
tivessem uma cordinha e ela vai
a caneta assombrada Olha isso eu acho
que com Mágico
[Música]
usar 13 elásticos
vem comigo vamos precisar de três
elásticos e uma cola bem forte Ok vocês
podem usar a cola Super 3 ou esta o hu
super Sei lá uma qualquer o que vocês
têm que fazer em casa antes de tudo é
cortar um elástico ao meio passado por
dentro do outro elástico desta maneira e
colar este elástico e com muito cuidado
ok a Dark Mas isso não fica meio Tosco
não pessoal reparem só aquele continua
super forte apesar de ter cola aqui ele
é completamente elástica Ok e passa bem
despercebido porque meio que a cola de
reto elástico e o elástico meio que se
junta outra vez Então fica bem
resistente como é que vai ser feito o
truque simples vamos pegar nos dois
elásticos ok Um deles eu recomendo que
seja até o que tem a cola porque ele é
mais sensível então vamos pegar nele
Vamos meio que enrolar assim e deixamos
só este de Fora este aqui fica todo por
dentro da mão ok
um dois três quando bate a terceira
vocês soltam o elástico que tem aqui na
mão abanam e ao mesmo tempo enquanto
fazem isto vocês meio que fecham aqui os
dedos só para não saber o que tem aqui o
elástico e rapidamente enquanto a pessoa
está entretida com o efeito você já
colocam elástico dentro do bolso e
abanam sempre agitam sempre assim
elásticos que é para a pessoa focar o
olhar nos elásticos Enquanto isso a
vossa mão já subiu e tem aqui os dois
elásticos a pessoa até pode analisar
porque ela nem vai reparar aqui neste
pequeno corte Ok mostrem que eles tão
completamente juntos que é algo
impossível Ok e aqui está feito o nosso
truque do elástico
este truque de Magia é muito visual
choca muitas pessoas e é super fácil de
se fazer na escola em qualquer lugar
para fazer este efeito é muito simples
vamos colocar um indicador por cima da
nossa orelha aqui bem por cima vamos
colocar o Polegar aqui dentro dobrar a
hora ali em cima e com o mesmo dedo
indicador vamos pegar a parte de baixo e
meio que juntar a orelha e aqui está
Pessoal este é o efeito Parece mesmo com
o dedo atravessou a nossa orelha depois
podem esticar um pouco brincar aqui um
pouquinho e olha só o efeito
aqui fiz uma coisa errada eu não posso
simplesmente soltar o dedo Ok o que eu
recomendo é quando acabam de fazer o
efeito meio que giram a cabeça e fazem
isto ó como se tivessem meiga tapar o
buraco entendem ó assim eu sei que você
já estavam a tentar enquanto eu estava a
explicar se vocês são um desses já
deixem like aqui no vídeo e inscrevam-se
para mais um vídeo deles água que se
transforma em coca-cola
[Música]
lá então a revelação de como transformar
água em coca-cola esta vai impressionar
toda a gente apenas tem um sinal vocês
depois não podem beber a coca-cola e já
vão perceber porquê e onde é que está o
truque o truque está aqui na nossa tampa
vamos utilizar uma tinta acrílica ou de
como que eram chamar vamos colocar
bastante tinta aqui por cima desta forma
podem ficar descansados que a tinta não
cai porque é uma tinta acrílica Então
ela fica bem agarrada lá em cima e é
importante ter só esta quantidade porque
quando nós agitarmos é importante que a
água consiga bater com bastante força
aqui em cima e depois é só ajeitar em
três dois um
e aqui está como por magia a água
transforma-se em coca-cola Este é um
efeito bastante visual muito bonito
mesmo os vossos amigos vão ficar
impressionados só não dá para fazer ao
contrário né Espero que vocês se tornem
mais que esteja sucesso e já que estão
aqui assistam também este vídeo pessoal
é um esconde esconde aqui em casa com
YouTubers tá muito bom mesmo para sei lá